Pewds, You have to play the joy of creation
It's super scary
SHHHHHUTUP
SHHHHUTUP
Number one horror gamer on YouTube I never get scared of
A - NY -THING!!
Whenever I get scared *boom* dab away. That's right. Aboom. Joy of creation. We played this a while ago, but it now has a
Story mode.
Oh It's a little scary. Boohoo.
Let's play it!
Oh, okay...
funky music *dances*
*dab* *dab* *dab*
Hell yeah, so far. I am absolutely terrified
By the God, I'm so scared. I'm shaking. Look at me.
"Uh, Hello?"
"What are you doing in our house?" Sorry I was just looking for a SHIT!
Little kid: "Is the stranger ok?"
"Yes, yes, he's okay. Don't worry. He just seems..."
"...confused? Uh excuse me, sir?"
"Can you tell me your name?" You guys have any chicken nuggets? "If you won't talk, I'm calling the police."
"You can't just barge into someone's house like this." I ordered a 6-Pack and I got five
Woman: "Honey what's going on?"
I'm looking for chicken nuggets. Come on! Ah, these bitches better give me my chicken nuggets!!
"Michael!"
"I, uh, mean  my uh, my name, it's Michael." (Jeff)
"I'm Michael, I uh, you asked me that... before..."
Little kid: "Daddy, Michael kinda sounds like you!"
Woman : "Excuse me, but..."
"Just what are you doing in our house?"
"The sun's about to go down... and"
"I don't think you should be here." "Yeah I was just saying that you, uh, you look a little bit roughed up."
"What happened to you?" He's clearly like a drug addict like why don't you just kick him out?
Michael: "I'm sorry but I just.."
"I just don't know."
Little kid: "Michael should get up!"
"The floor is bad."
"Daddy, can we help Michael?"
"Michael can come in. It would be bad to leave him outside."
~Pewds thinks about his life~
"After that, dad carried the stranger to a guest room."
"He thanked me for convincing my parents to let him rest in our house for a night."
"Or at least while he collected his thoughts."
Okay, press x to continue, press spacebar to stand and sit up. Press left to interact with objects, look up.
*static noises*
Michael: "Hello? Hello hello? Uh."
"Hey, little Nicky! It's me, Michael." I'm sleeping in a baby crib? "Don't say anything back to me, okay? There are monsters around that'll hear you if you do."
"Now, don't be scared Nick, okay?"
"Listen to me and we'll defeat those monsters, alright?"
"Okay, so these monsters might look-..." I'm playing as a baby
"-Don't look at them too long or you'll feel weird and see creepy things"
"When you do turn on your desk lamp."
"Next to your bed, you will feel safe there."
"The more you stare at the scary monsters, the worse you'll feel." Okay
Oh this is cool. "Ok, first things first. Uh, Freddy the Fuzzy Brown Bear"
"He's at the window"
"He will peek inside"
"Close your curtains"
"and keep them closed until you hear him leave or else he will get inside."
"Then there's Bonnie"
"The ill-tempered Bi- Bunnie"
Oh My God ! Its Five Fucken ... Five Nights at Fred- pack ... "He will knock on the door to let you know he´s there"
"So when he's next to your bed pretend to sleep until you hear him leave." Ok." Alright, you got all that ?"
It was ALOT, but i- Ok." Great, ok listen, i have to go little buddy."
"Listen, just hang in there. They will leave at 6 AM, Im sure of it"
"You can do this !"
*Thunder*
Okay, well this should be easy, okay. Easy. Easy peasy lemada peasy
What's up ? TOP of the mornin'
It's very cool. I love how this fan made game is fucking
better-looking than
the FNAF games. Jesus Christ
It's Impressive
Like this is Free
*noises*
Shut up!
Okay, we just got to make it to the morning
No problem. No problem, I'm really good at FNAFf games.
Everyone knows ... Knows me as the FNAF guy
Am I right ? That's me.
MARRRRRRRR *burp* RRRRR
okay...
Well this is fun ...
having a... having a good time.
Aw shit! closet, turn up the light and sit in the bed
*sits in bed* :O
Right ? That's what I had to do right ?
Do I not get like a little teddy bear or something I can hug down here ?
Helllooow ??
Awww dats spoooky mayn
Imma turn on the lights again *clicking* Okay, we're fine.
We're fine. My nam-  *noise*  Where did that ...?
*Gasp* Noo, No
Stop. Stop
This is scaring me..
No! I mean, I'm not scared!
AAAAAAHHHH
AAAAH
Stap
(Scared Pewds)
Graaaah!
(ok he lost his shit haha)
WTF
haha
What happened? Okay. Let's try that again, Jesus Christ. I didn't last long
Just like real life am I right ? ha ha top of the Mornin to you
Okay, oh
Shit, it's Jeff
Let's just sit here
and chill
*chilling*
zzzjust chilling, we're just chilling everybody
~Five night at Freddy's best game ever !!!~
~So scary when they jump in my face~
So glad there's more Fnaf games. I really feel like we're not getting enough of those
That's why I wake up all the time in the middle of the night cold sweat
More Fnaf games ... More fnaf !!!  We need more fnaf games!!
Why are there not more fnaf games?
Aww Shit dog, you're not welcome here dog.
*Noises*
dafuq is that sound?
How long do I have to keep them closed?
Alright, we're fine. Who did that, who said that hello !?
Keep this on now. Thank you. Thank you everybody. I
ain´t scared by the way
My name a Poodiepie
Never get scared of anyth-... Okay... All right. So turn off the light, am I right? There we go. what'cha gon' do son? Huh?
What´cha gonna fucking do?!
*regrets*
Oh God!! Ooh, that´s creepy as fuck!
Go back in your room chicken boy! I don't want´cha here anymore.
I don't care if you want my butt. That's right!! Now, let's turn on the light again. Cause my name a Jeff.
See I ain't scared. I ain´t scared for shit dog. I'll fight you aaaall
My McGregor accent. ~I fight you all. I ain´t scared~
You just a little chicken. Chiip chiip chiip chiip chiip chiip chiip
CHIIIIIIIIIIP
Ho! Ma name a Jeff, go away!
See, I´m good at these games, okay, I...
*get´s distracted by sounds*
Aaaw, okay, all right calm down.
Oh fuck dawg
~Excusez moi? you're not welcome here~ Oh fred, you fucking bitch! get out!!
Oh shit, oh shit. Oh, don't spook me!
*noise*
We cool? we cool! Alright, anyone else? Let´s turn on the lights. I´m a little spooked out, to be honest. What is 2:00 a.m.
Okay, that means aah... four more hours. That's fucking BULLSHIT!! Can´t you just let me sleep?!
For five fucking... who do that?! I don't know...
Oh that´s Freddy...
Fuck, I gotta sleep...
*sleeps*
Now what? I am asleep. I'm a soo sleepy.
How long?
*doesn´t get scared at all*
What the fuck was that?! What did I do then? What the hell did I do?! I did it!!
This is bullshit!!
It's a pretty cool idea that you're playing as a baby in a crib. like really vulnerable. It's trying to protect yourself
It´s a very ma name a jeff
Alright, hes gone. Okay, let´s turn back on the lights.
Never mind then. hey buddy :) You want to fuck? you want to smash? let me smash, come on
Come on. Come on. I´ll show you my diii...
AAAAAAAAAAAAAH
Hahaha, that was good. That was really good. Bonnie will attack you if you're up, shut the lights and sit down.
Okay, I didn´t sit down. I think I said this before, but it's like
If someone runs up to you and goes like *BUUH* you will get scared the first time most likely
But if someone keeps doing it, it's just kind of annoying
And I think that's the problem with these type of games
They don't really bring anything else
It's all jump scares, which is also the genius of it because that's what people want really. People just want jump scares.
I get it, but it's still fun. It's still cool. I I'm really impressed by this is a fan-made game
This is really fucking cool. Have you guys ever had like a really creepy experience as a kid?
Because I remember I had one of the freakiest things ever. It was like...
I was a really young kid kind. I remember how... Stop! and
I swear I saw like aah from this distance. I saw like a skeleton approached me
maybe I was too young to really understand that it was a dream or something like that, but
It really it really left a scar on me like I really remember it so clear
What I don't know what I have to do with Chica
You want some chicken nuggets Chica? Come on. We can chill man. We can share we can hang out
I think what a fucking bitch, what a loser.
I think we're doing okay. This time. What time is it - oh my gosh, just oh
This is getting creepy now. I'm not going to lie. This is pretty cool
Come on 2:00 a.m.. Come on
*intense focus*
Okay, we're back at 2:00. Oh fuck my dick hole jesus... sorry
Is he gone?
Ooh, that was creepy
Jesus, oh my God, gave me goosebumps.
Oh fuck
It's like chill guy
Did I fuck up? I think I fucked up
Fuck this is... I take back everything I said
Go away. Thank you. Jesus. What time is it? Come on, I gotta make it til three at least Jesus
I always just die here
Shut up Chica. He's out there. He's out there. He's out there
He´s gone okay. We're good. We're good. We're doing good. What time it's three three three come on, baby come on man
Come on, man. We can do this man 3 am in the morning
Okay, we're fine, We'll wait for it. We'll wait. Oh
Fuck Chica check out how many times I gotta tell you I didn't eat the chicken nuggets all right. They were vegan
Thank you my God. What a bitch
Come on, man. Give me four
Is that all you got?!
Shit you not welcome here son. You know that
They were fake chicken, I promise
I swear to you, oh, God
How many are going to scare me? calm down dude
Oh this game is a little hard. It's just like Dark souls
No, I can do this damn it. I know I can, I'm the best gamer alive. That's goddamn right. Thank you. Thank you
Look, I'm being a good boy. I'm sleeping look at me sleep everybody. Fuck that's Chica. Has he left yet.
He left
But then I can't, cause Chica's here. I can't turn on the lights
I think it's probably better if I keep the lights on for now, Chica
Okay that hurt, that hurt real bad
You got to do what you got to do
Okay, It's still just 4 okay. I can't close the window right now Freddie. If you wouldn't mind I like
I don't know what's happening. I don't think I'm in a very good condition right now
This is hard. This is really fucking hard
Okay, it's three, and I think we're doing pretty well this time. I can't I can't really tell
My God this game takes long to complete
It's like one fuck up and you're dead boy
And sometimes two of them come at the same time and you're like?
What do I do? Oh God look at that. It's like what do I do? I'm sleeping I swear!
Look, I'm sleep
Close the door
Thank you
Still alive man
Chica man, how you doing buddy? You want to come here?
Is that...what's that sound? Chica fuck off like I don't have time
it's four
Fuck off Chica. I'm trying to sleep, you're ugly. You've always been ugly. You look bad in a bikini
Fuck me
Jesus. I don't mean to be so mean okay
But it's 4:00 in the morning. I'm trying to sleep here.
Oh God Fox is here and Freddy's at the window
What do I do if they come at the same fucking time?
Fox will never be able to kill you unless you look at him. Look at this. There - there's two of them
Fuck man. It's so much happening. I just want to sleeeeep
Oh, oh I was like it was pretty chill for a while. Oh god, that's foxie
Doing pretty good this time. I think, I think we can do it. I think, I seriously think we can
Hey, chica. You wanna see these, you like what you're seeing, baby. I guess not
If we can make it to five I'll be like okay. There's a chance. There is a chance we can do it
*singing* take a chance, take a chance chance chance  take a chance
Oh shit dog
Fuck chica, I don't have time for you. You want some of the ass boy. I spread ma cheek for you
Fucking pervert. I know he wanted it.
Oh this is bad
Fuck it's 5, it's 5, it's 5, it's 5, it's 5. It's fucking 5:00. Oh fuck he is still here fuck, fuck
Fuck I fucked up
sleep
What's happening? Why is he not going away? Okay? Hey? How are you doing?
"Foxy can't kill you if you look at him" fuck off
Unless you look at him. UNLESS you look at him! Fuuuuuuck ooooohh
It's 5, it's 5, it's 5. Come on. Come on
fuck
fuck Chica is here too
and foxy
Like what am I supposed to do?
Fam
Get up, get up you fucking pussy
click on the light
I can't. I think I'm dead. Oh okay, I'm not dead
Hey, how you doing buddy? Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. That's right, we're fine
We're totally fine, look I did it guys
Look at that. It's five. If I turn around he's going to be there, so I'm not gonna do that
What's happening? What's happening? Fuck! God damn it.
Wait, what?
What?!
FUCK!!
One more try
Fucking, damn it. It's so hard. You have to play so god damn long
It's like 20 minutes every attempt
10-15 minutes
15 minutes every attempt
fuck
Last time. I'm going to fucking do it. Okay. I know I can do it. Shut up. This game is not like Dark Souls.
This lamp is my respect for women right now okay, and I'm charging this fucking light. Come on lamp. I pray to you. Come on
It's fucking five
JESUS CHRIIIIIST! COME ON!
I've been so respectful
Come on. Go the fuck away
Fuck. Fuck off bonnie. I ain't got time for you, bitch
Chica is here now. Fuck off Chica
Come on. Is that all you got?
Come on.  I've got this. Fucking got this. What do you want bitches?
Smash that like! Fuck yeah! Easy. Not like Dark Souls.
Hell yeah, so fucking easy!
Dab, dab, dab, bruh
Wow
That was so easy
My God. I was...
*random noises* Fuck yeah! Fuck yeah! Fuck yeah!
Fuck. Oh, there's more awh leave a like if you want me to do more. Imma do more in the future
Thank you, Sister fisters and as always
sister fister